de l'Union européenne a choisi
d'investir très fortement dans ce
secteur
[Musique]
alors l'intelligence artificielle on a
vu c'est un tsunami et on n'arrête pas
une tsunami avec une digue en revanche
on peut agir et on peut être acteur
alors c'est vrai que c'est un débat on a
tous vu ce que ça pouvait être
l'intelligence artificielle on a vu le
pape en doudoune on a vu l'arrestation
de Donald Trump alors qu'elle n'était
pas faite donc on voit combien ça peut
créer des fausses informations ça peut
remplacer des choses qui existent des
gens même donc le temps n'est pas à
l'interdiction le temps il est établir
des zones de risques sur son utilisation
pour savoir ce qui acceptable et ce qui
n'est pas du tout comme par exemple les
systèmes de notation sociale qui
existent en Chine et que nous ne voulons
pas voir dans notre continent
[Musique]
pour ça il faut investir massivement
dans ce secteur et puis l'Union
européenne légifère actuellement sur
l'intelligence artificielle et nous
avons un texte très important en cours
qui est l'acte sur l'intelligence
artificielle donc ça l'Union européenne
s'en occupe et dans le courant des
quelques mois ce sera voté au Parlement
européen
l'intelligence artificielle permet
d'être beaucoup plus précis sur les
diagnostics et donc de mieux traiter les
malades c'est un véritable atout aussi
qu'on va parler de mobilité pour les
voitures sans chauffeurs notamment elle
peut nous apporter beaucoup c'est pour
ça que l'Union européenne a choisi
d'investir très fortement dans ce
secteur
[Musique]
merci le rock d'avoir été le premier
continent à réguler l'Internet